- What is that all for?
The colors, what's this for?
- You know like, uh.
- And what're those for?
(upbeat music)
(typing)
- This is certainly not
the no-makeup makeup look.
This is a lot of makeup.
I would go so far as to
say this is the opposite
of no makeup.
- I think if you wanna do it,
you wanna wear makeup
to look like you're not wearing makeup,
like, it's 2016, do it.
- Makeup remover wipes are
the only thing you should need
for a no-makeup look.
- I'll do very good.
Yeah, like, if not excellent.
- I think I'm gonna crash and burn.
But, I mean, I'm already done, right?
No makeup.
- It'll probably take me
ten minutes to re-create
'cause I'm just gonna go for it.
- It's a nice presentation.
I don't, I'm just gonna
use maybe one item.
(dramatic music)
- I'm so shiny.
How did this happen?
This is devastating.
(making beeping noise)
- [Man On Left] Do you
have to make that noise?
- Yes.
- Foundation!
- Apply foundation.
- What, what is foundation?
- Uh...
- Is there, like, a specialty,
like, size we're supposed to use?
- We could just use the big one
'cause you've got a big face.
- Creamy beige, am I creamy beige?
What is my skin tone, like, clear?
- That looks like powder
to set everything in.
(ding)
- So we just kinda, like--
I'm gonna put the lid on.
- That's at the end.
- Do that.
[Woman Off-Screen]
- Seven minutes, (bleep).
- Oh my, what about these?
- Oh no, this is terrible.
(squeals)
- This is not working.
- You gotta make that makeup face, like.
- [Man On Left] That looks soft.
- [Man On Right] Is that blush?
- Oh, that's, hm.
- Whoop.
- [Man On Left] I don't
think that's concealer.
- Boop.
- I am goin' out.
(record scratch)
- [Man On Left] Woah, you're sparkling.
I'm not puttin' that on my face, no way.
- Oh my God, no!
(laughs)
No!
- [Man On Left] You're so glittery.
- I've ruined it.
- Gotta wipe it.
Oh no. (laughs)
- I gotta start over.
- You look like a oompa loompa.
- Makeup is just the
grossest thing in the world.
It's just a bunch of, like, mud.
- Use concealer on under
eyes and any blemishes.
[Woman Off-Screen]
What, what?
No.
- We're okay.
- What is concealer?
- See, isn't this fun?
Aren't you having fun?
- Optional step, bake your face.
What does that mean?
- Optional, I don't, I just
heard optional, I don't care.
- Bake my face.
That's good.
- Bronze perimeters of face.
- This one looks like the surface of Mars.
- This feels nice.
I can see why girls do this for hours.
- How many more minutes do we have?
- Oh, (bleep), it's all over my shirt.
(playful music)
- How do they look?
Are they filled in?
- Boop.
Boop.
- Is it supposed to go
this way or this way?
- Highlight cheek bones.
What better to highlight with than yellow?
- Oh yeah.
Maybe he was born with it.
♫ River's wide and I am driftin' ♫
- Voila.
(chuckles)
- We're beautiful.
- This looks terrible.
- I think I had an
issue with all 14 steps.
- I understand why a lot of women
might wanna just wear makeup
to kind of hide certain things
that you don't like.
- Might as well have no makeup on.
You don't need it.
- So if you wanna wear makeup
for the no-makeup look,
(bleep) do it.
- But if you suck at applying
makeup on, don't even try it.
(upbeat music)